you've just come back to your hometown
Island for your dead friend's funeral
and you find out that her death wasn't
an accident and now you're being hunted
down by these terrifying monsters called
Shadows all because you found the power
to change the past and it's not going to
be that easy you'll have to die again
and again before you'll have any chance
of saving everyone you love I'm going to
break down the mistakes made what you
should do and how to beat summertime
render part two oh man these kids are
going to get themselves brutally ripped
torn shot smooshed poisons by nasty
Shadow Demons and it's only episode 13.
shinpei here has just discovered that he
has an insane power he can relive the
exact same day over and over again each
time he dies along with his best friend
ushio who's actually a fake human I'll
explain in a sec he's failed to save the
world and just saw all of his teammates
get their heads blown off by these
things called Shadows with all hope lost
he quickly dies and repeats the same day
all over again but this time with a new
game plan to save the world okay this is
a lot of information but basically this
kid came to this island for his best
friend's funeral then in the span of one
day finds out a bunch of crazy like
for one there's these alien crazy Shadow
Demon things that kill people and have
the power to copy the identity of
whoever they kill and it turns out
shinpei's best friend Blondie over here
was killed by a shadow who actually
turns out to be a good guy long story
and he gets sent back one day into the
past for the millionth time shinpei will
now need to re-recruit all of his
friends again to stop the shadow God
Jaime he needs to stop hyenae from
consuming everyone in the town within
the next 24 hours or she'll be able to
leave the island okay now we're all
caught up and now back to the story
shimpei and Shadow ushio suddenly appear
in front of their two teammates from the
last time Loop shinpei tells this old
man in glasses girl that they've met
before that he's relived this day five
times already his plans to stop the
Shadows has failed every single time
great track record but each time he's
gained new information about what the
hell is really going on but the old man
is not listening and suddenly figures
out that shadow Uso is surprised a
shadow and prepares to blast off her
sweet face and ruin shinpei's plans okay
whoa whoa whoa I would say hold the
music hold up stop it don't shoot her
this is insane because right now there's
so much going on Shin pad this part
needs to tell his teammates to calm down
the reason why old man is freaking out
is because Shadow usho is a part of a
mysterious race of creatures that have
inhabited this island for centuries in
secret and now the shadow God is trying
to reach its full terrifying power and
to top it off every time shinpei goes
back into the past the time from which
he goes back into the past gets moved up
to a certain date the Summer Festival
every time shimpei dies he doesn't go
back to the exact same spot in the
previous day oh no no the amount of time
that he's able to go back into the past
actually gets less every single time
which means some events in the past are
starting to become permanent and that
means despite his powers he doesn't have
the time literally to mess around Shadow
ushio is the only good guy or well good
girl on shinpei's team who can actually
go with him back into the past which is
why he can't let her die because she's
crazy useful she's got a bunch of really
sweet crazy Shadow powers that don't
make sense but just roll with it if I
was shimpei I would have thought up of a
way to speed up this process of having
to prove the validity of my story to
these two each time we come back to life
while I know that these people are from
the last time Loop they technically
don't know me in this time Loop and that
means the first tactic that we should
have used would have been to ask them
point blank in the last time Loop the
answers to some of their most personal
information that only they could have
known like when was the first time they
had a near-death experience or when was
the time they lost there well you know
what cart making them go into nasty
details about the specifics and then by
using this information each time we came
back to life we simply could have proven
that we've met them before by telling
them their most personal information
this would have saved me a lot of time
which we don't have much of anyways
Shadow ushod tells old man that she's
now on the good guy team and tells him
to chill out shinpei proves that he's
the real deal by revealing that he knows
glasses girl's true identity and reveals
that she is an expert Shadowhunter with
a secret power and she has come back to
her hometown to stop the Shadows but he
tells her that without him and ushio
there to help they'll all die within the
next 24 hours anyways glasses girl
finally believe shinpei and thinks that
since he can time Loop one of his eyes
must belong to the shadow God of this
island this girl Hayne somehow her eye
went into shimpei and that is how he got
these Powers concerned about the mark on
his hand glass's girl asks shinpei where
he got it but he tells her that they
don't have time to make small talk
because that was his biggest mistake
shinpeir then warns her what will happen
in the future if they don't stop the
Shadows this OG shadow guy and his bad
guy team will feed everyone on the
island to hiney the island God and shall
finally be strong enough to leave the
island he quickly comes up with a game
plan to capture this little girl who
looks super innocent and cute but is
actually being controlled by Heine too
weak to be Super Evil and overpowered
Heine uses this little girl and her
super fake Shadow family to travel
around the island undiscovered but if
they can capture her then Shadow usho
might be able to use her Shadow powers
to finally destroy Heine nearby
shinpei's close friend's dad this guy
caused to somebody mysterious and asks
about shinpei why are him and glasses
girl looking into the early deaths on
the the islands and thinks that they're
up to something this guy is working with
the bad guys just so you know but the
mysterious voice on the phone says that
they'll handle taking out ushio
shimpei's greatest asset by taking out
her family and shinpei very soon later
shinpei's gang decides to redo their
plan the exact same way they did in the
last time Loop because that makes total
sense but this time they're going to try
to erase the little girl using Shadow
ushio's Powers shimpy thinks because of
his powers he can now pretty much
predict the future but he has no idea
how wrong he is cautious like before
glasses girl heads into the little
girl's house and repeats her actions
just like the last time Loop by kicking
ass it's super awesome and everyone
thinks that this will be a piece of cake
but suddenly they see her fly right out
this window and she hits the floor her
arms have been severed she tells them
something in this time Loop has gone
horribly wrong right as her face gets
smashed in by Jaime's bodyguard OG's
Shadow everyone is horrified and doesn't
understand how OG's Shadow and little
girl could have predicted their moves
but that's when this evil little snipe
of a girl reveals that in one of the
previous time Loops insert video here
see it check it out it's a good video
she marked shinpei's arm with her hand
and absorbed the memory of glasses girl
the last time she killed her and because
of this somehow she now has the ability
to follow shinpei into any time Loop he
goes to and oh by the way she knows
about all of their old plants that they
tried to do before shimpei stands Frozen
in fear as oshi's Shadow swiftly kills
old man and gets ready to kill him too
but Shadow usho quickly chops off his
head and recessed the time Loop defeated
the two travel back in time to try to
kill the little girl or Hine all over
again alright plot twist bigger than
when Akira ended up kicking the bucket
in Devilman crybaby the only card that
shinbei had up his sleeve little girl
can now do it too to an extent while
going back into the past Shadow ushio
talks to shimpei and says that she
thinks that Jaime is sort of
piggybacking off of shinpei's time Loop
meaning she always is going to be able
to find him no matter how many times he
Loops back or where and that she already
knows all the stuff that shinpei did in
his previous time Loop which pretty much
means that he has to come up with with
some new plans that he hasn't done
before which makes this anime one of
those rare ones where the bad guys are
actually smart shinbei having one of
jaane's eyes means that he could have
assumed that the bad guy from the get-go
would have probably had some powers that
he didn't know about G maybe should have
considered that one shinpei he should
not have assumed that his good guy team
had the upper hand just because he heard
some Powers after all his eye does
belong to Heine the enemy shimpia
thought way too little of his enemy and
got lazy with his planning even though
he tried his best he should have thought
a little bit more and also shimpei cares
way too much about his friends everyone
dying here proves shinpei's greatest
flaw he wants to save the world without
losing anybody and in particular this
close friend of his called Mia because
now while this girl may not seem
important compared to the other badass
boss babes on shipei's team she's
actually the most important person here
to shinping the Shadows know how
important Shadow ushio is to shimpei's
plans but if they figure out how close a
meal is really with shimpei then they'll
likely go after her and if she dies Shin
pay will without a doubt try to reset
his time Loop in order to save her due
to a strong attachment to her aside from
trying to stop the bad guys shambi
should have tried a little harder on how
to either hide meal and keep her safe
from harm or keep her close to him at
all times due to this reason or the very
least began preparing for the cold hard
fact that some of the people on his team
might not be alive by the end of this
adventure because if the enemy figures
out his weakness it's all over shinpei
arrives back in the past but this time
really into the past and not his he
realizes that he's looking into someone
else's past glasses girl's memory her
past and he is so confused and he sees
glasses girl now a kid on the island
shimpei watches her sit with her
classmates and this kid and teenage
glasses girl then tells them that she's
made a new friend in the forest that's
not weird but they don't believe her so
she takes them to the dark woods and
tries to show off her French through
this window but no one shows up making
fun of her the friends leave as glasses
girl's mysterious friend finally appears
and chimpei sees who it is and he is
shocked it's Jaime he's Beyond stunt and
realizes that his teammates used to be
friends with his worst enemy whoa this
is a big one shinpei being unable to
control his powers basically means that
his powers have now turned him into a
walking dream catcher instead of a web
that catches dreams he is a web that
catches anyone's past if they get too
close to him and this could be useful
now while it might be easy to panic at
this point this discovery of his could
actually be the hidden Ace up Our Sleeve
because by getting an intimate look into
the lives of other people I would begin
to try to test this Theory out right
away in the next time loop I know I have
a limited amount of times that I can go
back into the past but I would be
willing to sacrifice one or two Loops to
figure this out the next time I go back
into the past I'm going to try to will
myself to be able to access information
about the people who are near the
shadows and learn about their Origins
through a person who might be able to
clue Us in on the Shadow's weaknesses
which by the way my good weeps there is
somebody who knows about the shadows and
their weaknesses and that is this guy
redhead guy's dad our team member's
death basically redhead guy's dad worked
for the town corner office and we all
found out in the previous video that
he's been working for the Shadows for
years feeding them real humans because
he wants to save his wife so romantic
but not important he's a sort of good
guy doing really bad things out of luck
and even then that's not important the
real important thing is that if we can
get to him we can use our powers to try
and look into his past and find out any
info that we can that we could leverage
against heinek because he likely knows a
lot about her shimpei watches glasses
girl and his mortal enemy hang out and
do normal friends stuff sort of and sees
how sweet and kind Jaime used to be he
continues to watch the memory when he
hears Hayne mentioned that she's now
gotten very hungry too hungry to even
function and the food that glasses girl
has been bringing her up until now is no
longer enough and now she needs to feed
glasses girl runs off to quickly find
more food for her but that was her
biggest mistake too hungry to wait Heine
heads off into the forest to look for
food but that's when she suddenly runs
into a certain somebody that glasses
girl knows and she uses her Shadow
powers to devour him whole and she
copies his soul into her body but out of
nowhere glasses girl shows back up and
is shocked Hayne has killed her brother
now that fortunately her munchy Munchies
have gone away and now she's less crazy
Jaime realizes what she's just got and
begins to freak out so much so that her
magical eyeball freaking pops out of her
body and runs away it's gross and the
Shadow Spirit of glasses girl's brother
escapes heiny's body and jumps right
into glasses girl heinig disappears into
the ground and two evil Shadows show up
this little piece of tries to
attack her but she is saved by old man
yeah he's still old but he's less old
but unfortunately for them he's no match
for these shadows and is about to get
killed when glass's girl's brother takes
over glasses girl's body easily killing
these two and saves Old Man glasses girl
then realizes that thanks to Heine she
has not fused her mind and soul with
that of her brothers and they now share
the same body meaning she'll be able to
switch control between her controlling
her own body and her brother controlling
her body whenever glasses girl wants
this to happen she's now gained
semi-temporary Shadow superpowers oh
yeah and it gets better she now has the
power to even see two seconds into the
future somehow but that's not important
the point is this is how glass's girl
and old man met and why my classes girl
left the island years ago okay we've
just had big developments that we need
to address the first is the reset Point
keeps getting later and later meaning
that if he keeps resetting this time
Loop his saved life span will soon begin
at the point where it all ends at the
Summer Festival and at that point it's
gonna be too late to save anything but
to be honest there is something that he
should have noted way sooner is that
glass's girl royally screwed chimpei
over so bad and this whole time he
didn't even bother to maybe share this
information with me like what gifts she
never told me about her old relationship
with hining if I was him I would have
walked up to her very calmly and
demanded to know why she didn't tell us
about this important piece of
information I'm calm I'm calm I'm fine
I'm fine I'm fine I'm just saying that
maybe it would have been a good idea for
us to be able to go check out the place
where it all began because by us doing
this sooner we could have probably saved
me a couple of time Loops but hey I'm
not salty about it I'm just mad he has
resources around him why doesn't he use
them even more and why doesn't even
bother to ask more questions about his
resources AKA glasses girl but then
again he's a young kid who's been given
the tall order of trying to save the
world with time traveling superpowers
where he has to constantly see everyone
he loves die over and over again so
maybe we should cut him some slack but
later that night shinpei calls everyone
over that he spot with before to meet
him at the school hall Shadow usho then
uses her powers to download the memories
of the previous time Loops into
everyone's brain catching everyone up to
speed gee isn't that convenient
including the Dead real usio sister Mio
who is another one of shinpei's best
friends who has a very big crush on our
main men but who cares about that
shinpei then tells everyone that Mio
here has a shadow and that he's found
out that Mio's Shadow will be coming
this way soon and this time they need to
be ready to fight nearby old man is
taking watch outside of the school when
he is suddenly stabbed in his big
thinker by Shadow Mio she takes hold of
his rifle meanwhile shinbei continues to
give an epic speech about saving the
world when he suddenly appears in his
kitchen he has no idea how he got here
and he then realizes that his day's just
been reset which means somehow he just
died shout out ushio then burst into
shinpei's apartment and she tells him
that she followed him back through the
loop and brought the mail in this time
Loop up to speed as well great she tells
shimpei that the Shadows killed him in
the last time Loop and shimpy then
realizes that the Shadows have now
started to kill shimpei on purpose and
they're no longer trying to capture him
alive shinpei sweats a little bit and
reveals to these two the worst news of
all he's losing his powers and if he
keeps dying at this rate he'll soon die
for good and this is what the Shadows
must have figured out he tells them he
thinks he has one more time Loop left
before he dies forever with such high
stakes they then quickly head back to
the school to try and recruit their
Shadow killing Army once again but this
time with a different plan Shin pay
sweats and reveals to them the worst
news of all the start of each time Loop
is pushed forward with every reset
meaning some events are started to
become permanent if he keeps dying at
this rate he'll soon die for good and
this is what the Shadows have figured
out as well okay this is really bad
shinpei has now finally realized that
there's a limit to his powers but now
also the bad guys have realized this too
and it's likely that Heine didn't
realize this initially until she latched
onto shimpei with her hand that one time
time and that's when shinpei royally
messed up because this changes the whole
dynamic of what's been going on up until
now and is actually a really big deal if
I was shinping I had to think about this
a little bit because before in our
previous video the Shadows knew about
our power sorta and that's when they
just tried to capture shinpei alive that
mindset actually gave shinpei a huge
Advantage but now all the bad guys have
to do is simply exploit shinpei's Power
by killing him again and again and again
until he dies for good and this approach
by the way is way less hard for them and
way more harder for us at this point in
order to effectively serve our mission I
would begin looking myself as more of a
general and use my teammates as more or
less troops because our powers made us
the strongest player of the game but now
we found out we have an Achilles heel
our power still make us the most
important player here in a way we are no
longer the dominating force that the bad
guys thought we were I would begin
assigning orders to certain people to my
team rather than being on the front
lines with them by using certain things
such as walkie-talkie cell phones as a
means of command and controlling and
understanding the situation from a save
distance and in this way I'll be out of
the direct line line of fire because we
don't have many more chances to be able
to screw this up and reset and go back
in time at the school shinpei tells them
that the Shadows know their strategy
from the last time Loop and now they
have to switch it up using the handprint
of Heine on his arm they plan to use it
and lure her away and kill her right in
the stadium hearing them come shinpei
quickly goes outside to battle the
shadow army face to face Shadow meal
then attacks shinpei but he quickly
escapes with Shadow ushio's help and
just then old man takes out some of the
evil minions and little girl gets a
little bit mad and goes after shimpei
with her Shadow parents while on
shinpei's side they get to work on
killing everyone else running fast
Shadow ushio and shimpei set glasses go
up to take out the rest of the incoming
Shadows firing left and right and doing
some sick hand-to-hand combat it's
amazing go watch it but that's when
glasses girl finally uses her future
seeing powers and sees shinpei about to
get shot so she takes a bullet for him
saving his life but is not what she
thinks she realizes that Heine must have
absorbed her powers as well in one of
the previous time Loops about to die she
gets saved last minute by old man man
allowing the good guys to get some
distance luring OG Shadow away and
little girl into this room they set up a
trap for them confused OG Shadow then
notices Shadow ushio's hair floating
above them using her powers she
transforms those strands of hair into
piles of gasoline because yeah she can
do that with her hair and this whole
place is about to blow up in flames and
shinpei throws a lit match on him
setting everything on fire oh it's
freaking awesome I love it thinking this
is the one thing that can take them out
the good guys watch the monster stream
in pain and little girl quickly tries to
escape but is shot down by Shin paint
wasting no Time shadow usually quickly
grabs little girl's finger sang a really
long good guy's speech and takes forever
to kill her and so because of this she
takes too long surprise surprise and she
gets grabbed by OG's Shadow and he drags
her into the fire shipei tries to stop
him but gets shot forcing him to watch
Shadow ushio get burned alive but that's
when ushio pulls a Switcheroo and tricks
OG's Shadow coming up from behind him
and gut punches him sideways she quickly
tries to scan his data but realizes
there's a human inside of this monster
and almost discovers the bad guy's true
identity but that's when this little
girl freaks out and quickly escapes with
her bad guy team putting out the fire in
an instant and prevents shinpei's crew
from figuring out the biggest secret out
there shinping quickly goes up to check
up on Shadow ushio and Shadow Usha
freaks out thinking like I know my
boyfriend died but he reveals that
Harry's sister I'm wearing a bulletproof
vest so he's Gucci and the Gang
celebrates their first little Victory
because For the First Time in all the
time Loops no one has died oh man isn't
that great this is a huge deal because
think about it basically the longer
shimpei stays alive in one time Loop the
more leeway he'd have with his time Loop
in case he did die imagine a cliff that
is constantly breaking off bit by bit as
time keeps moving forward that is the
reset point if shenpai falls behind that
line then he falls off the cliff and
will be dead for good but the longer he
stays alive the more and more time he'll
gain isn't that awesome I think it's
great but anyways back to the story
shinpei then finds out that his crew
managed to capture Mio's Shadow and
Shadow ushio cuts her mental link from
Jaime freeing Shadow meow sorta and they
get to work on making her a good guy
later that night she tells them that as
a shadow copy she now has all the
memories of Mia and that she will die in
one week if she doesn't kill the
original meal and take her place and she
reveals that since they cut her
connection to heinek she's now lost her
need to kill that my how convenient and
helpful shinpei then thinks that redhead
guy's dad probably knows what Haine
really wants since he's been helping the
bad guys for years redhead guy mentions
that he was supposed to meet his dad
tonight and the group prepares to tag
along with him to go visit his dad at
his evil daddy Clinic fearing the danger
headed their way Shadow meal is assigned
to protect the real male Maya that's
awkward she basically insinuates to the
real meal that she likes shinpei and it
gets really awkward the group quickly
reaches the terrifying clinic and
everything has been cleared out
suspicious shout out ushio then senses a
shadow nearby and they head down this
hallway hearing some noise from the
hospital basement and they prepare to go
down to where life doesn't exist
noticing bullet holes on the walls they
realize where they're headed to the
morgue then redhead guy's mom's
wheelchair is spotted and they get ready
to prepare for combat discovering a
secret room but they realize that one of
the main objectives of why they went
there also is that the real Shadow
ushio's body is not there anymore it's
been moved shinpei thinks the Shadows
must have moved her because they know
that had Shadow ushio been able to fully
copy the real dead ushio's body she
could have used the real dead ushio's
body to heal Shadow ushio my that's
complicated getting nervous Shadow ushio
asks shinpei if he wants to reset the
time Loop and try all of this again but
shinpei says Nope and is determined to
find redhead guy's dad they quickly
discovered this spooky hallway and
redhead girl which is redhead guy's
sister it's a long story mentions that
they used this secret tunnel to deliver
dead patience to Hine and in the
distance they noticed Ray head guy and
Girl's mom choking their dad shout out
usho quickly knocks out the mom and cuts
the connection between her and Jaime and
demands to know what evil pops knows he
tells them that Jaime ordered him to
speed up preparations for the Summer
Festival since she now knows that
chimpei is getting closer to stopping
them and they see that redhead guy's dad
has clearly lost it he tells his redhead
kid to join him in order to please
heinek but they tell him that yo she's
evil and is not going to keep the
promises she made to him but pops gets
mad and disarms redhead guy and tries to
kill his daughter whoa rude but uh-uh uh
it's not that easy he finds out it's
actually shadow Meow in Disguise
Switcheroo defeated he refuses to talk
so Shadow meal tries to copy him but
finds out something crazy he is immune
to being copied which means that he must
have been copied before it's strange and
evil pops thinks that she's wrong
because if he can't be copied then this
means that everything Hein has promised
him has been a lie it then tells them
that honey promised him that his entire
family would be copied into Shadows
including the kids once they're dead and
they would go to live on any eternity in
another dimension forever but out of
nowhere the crew notices one of evil
dad's nurses holding the real ushio's
corpse she tells them that the Shadows
have officially cut ties with daddy and
his useless family announcing to
everyone that in two days the world will
come to an end shinbei shoots a big
fatty right at her gray matter Bud
misses the gang thinks following her is
a trap that decide to focus their
attention on evil pups and he takes an
anime second and suddenly turns good and
begins to talk telling everyone that his
wife actually died long ago and this
woman here in fact is a shadow causing
redhead kid to freak out and realize why
his dad did what he did his dad just
really wanted to bring his whole family
together and he didn't care how or what
he had to do to do it the dad then says
that killing Jaime isn't that simple if
she dies then all the shadows will die
with her including his wife Aunt Shadow
ushio and Shadow meal but we don't care
about her shinpei freaks out for a hot
SEC but Shadow Usha puts on a brave face
and tells him they've had a good run but
they gotta get past it anime quick and
they do and they refocus on their
mission because they don't have much
time left evil pops wife then
emotionally slap some more sense into
Daddy and demands he helps them save the
kids and stop Jaime no matter what it's
a real cry Fest evil pops finally
decides to fully help them to save the
world okay so I know we just went
through a big crypto that it was so
emotional and beautiful but these guys
are missing the point Jaime is too weak
right now to leave her Cape that's a
good thing and that's why she's been
using this little girl to sort of VR her
way around town and this means that the
real key player here is OG Shadow he has
been her General he has been the leader
of her evil Shadow Demon Army he's been
the one carrying out most of their evil
plans and the one thing that also
doesn't make sense is that redhead guy's
evil dad told us something he said Heine
simply wants to go to a secret shadow
world and live out the rest of her days
free and in peace but judging from OG
Shadows batshit crazy personality I'm
having a real hard time believing that's
really what he OG Shadow wants as well
because it's a very real possibility
that OG's Shadow is not going to follow
the shadow God into this other world
having lived through many time Loops I
would say I have a pretty good idea as
to some of the psychological makeup of
OG Shadow and that this guy probably has
more evil intentions than even heinic
because if I'm shinpei and I saw the
past of glasses girl when she was with
Jaime we found out that unlike OG's
Shadow Heine genuinely wants to be set
free and at her core in the very
beginning wasn't that bad of a person
sort of I mean she did eat her brother
ouch but the point of all this wants
Shadow God Hine leaves there's gonna be
nothing to stop OG's Shadow especially
if we think about the huge reveal that
OG Shadow is part human which puts him
at risk for psychologically being
disloyal to heinek because the fact is
he is not a carbon copy of the shadows
and this makes him not as predictable
because if OG Shadow is part human then
that makes him just as untrustworthy to
hiney as he would be with shinpei or
anyone else or even me and this makes
him the biggest threat out here evil
daddy now turned into a good guy opens a
safe full of his patient records the
list has the names of all the people
that he's ever fed to Heine and he tells
him that he knows the true identity of
OG's Shadow he was the first child that
Hani ever gave birth to and was a
actually the founder of their family run
Clinic years ago what oh my gosh the
team then have their final nights rest
and they prepare to stop the Summer
Festival in two days the next day
shinpei wakes up and realizes that this
is the longest that he's ever been alive
in a Time Loop meaning the approaching
Edge of Time has now been pushed farther
back it means that he can now reset the
time Loop a few more times if he really
needs to well that's a good thing but he
begins to notice that it's not all Good
News Bears his eyes have now begun to
hurt and he has a minor headache that
has begun to get worse today's job will
be to hunt down more shadows and take
out some of their ranks before the final
battle at the Summer Festival they plan
to hit up all the previous areas where
they encountered Shadows the real Mio
tells Shadow ushio some great news she's
found some of the real dead ushio's hair
Tangled in the shower drain excited as
hell Shea uses the hairs to heal her
Shadow body because yeah she can do that
with the real dead ushio's hair and the
team heads out to kick ass champagne
Shadow usho hit up a bunch of houses
they've passed before as Shadow ushio
senses the presence of Shadows nearby
they follow the evil sent into the
forests when they suddenly hear screams
nearby and go to check it out
discovering the shadow that is about to
eat these children shinpei quickly kills
the shadow but he is horrified he's just
killed the shadow of his childhood
teacher they fill in the kids on all the
craziness of what just happened and tell
them to keep their mouth shut about what
they just saw but the horrors aren't
over they discover blood trails nearby
and realize it's fresh they suspect that
Jaime is consuming more people in order
to heal herself out of nowhere Shadow
ushio loses her mind for a second and
turns into a little Exorcist girl scary
she starts Whispering some creepy words
to herself and looks really evil but
then snaps out of it and the two quickly
move past it shinpei calls the team to
tell them that he and Shadow ushio have
only killed three shadows in total and
they have nearly found as many Shadows
like they have in previous time Loops he
thinks that the Shadows must not be
hiding to avoid suspicion and are trying
to rest up before the big battle at the
Summer Festival tomorrow unlike previous
time Loops honey has told them that
shinpei will be coming for them now and
they are fully alert shinbei has a talk
with his team and they begin to suspect
that the priest of the town this priest
might be in fact the human inside of
OG's Shadow redhead guy's dad has been
in contact with some bad guy for ages
and he thinks priest guy is OG Shadow
working at The Shrine this place will
also be where the Summer Festival aka
the end of the world will begin to take
place going unnoticed this guy has been
everywhere in the background since the
beginning I mean look at this look at
this and this he's been there the whole
time he's been around for years and all
of these Clues make him suspicious as
hell Shadow ushio says to go and
investigate him right now is risky but
shinpei thinks that he's smarter than
the enemy and wants to know what he's
thinking before he kills him he tells
his team to set up around the shrine and
wait for his signal in case goes
south he goes to meet priest guy with
Shadow ushio watching over him and these
two go inside to talk shinpei talks to
Prescott and tries to figure out how
suspicious this guy really is and asks
him if he knows what's really going on
this guy just laughs it off and thinks
he's crazy but shinpei then takes out
the picture that redhead guy's dad gave
them and shin paid demands to know how
he stayed the same age for over 70 years
he's caught pre-sky red-handed and
Shadow usho and the whole team gets
tense as hell oh back up a bit I feel
like I gotta explain some things
basically 300 years ago the people of
this island were starving to death and
then Heine showed up and copied the
first person at saw and then became
known as the god of the island she
murdered over 100 villagers and then
turned them into shadows and this is how
the island was saved because apparently
there was a food shortage so she just
killed all the real humans and the fish
were able to repopulate great thinking
about it in retrospect though it makes
sense that redhead guy's dad went into
medicine and Prescott and the other bad
guys went into religion if I was shinpei
I'm gonna think long and hard about
exactly what kind of conversation I'm
going to have because uh for one reason
he is wearing glasses glasses guy energy
it's a thing look it up and while there
could have been a tactical Advantage
with figuring out OG Shadow's actual
identity confronting this Baddie full-on
right in his face is way too risky since
this guy is OG Shadow we just literally
challenged him in his own home turf
which is probably not the best idea to
do right now this guy is still in his
human form which means that his shadow
body is probably some sort of armor that
protects them from harm and even worse
it acts like some sort of freaky freaky
Iron Man Nano suit that will cover him
up and protect him the moment we try to
hurt him and that means that at any
point he could literally ruin our plants
if he wanted to here's what I would have
done I would have lured him out of the
shrine away from his home turf and then
we'll be able to confront him head-on
we're gonna be in a better position of
strength and more likely not going to
get surrounded by evil Shadows that I'm
sure are hiding at every nook and cranny
of this freaky freaky scary looking
Temple that's my plan don't do it at his
home turf that's stupid priest guy
reveals an evil smile shinbei tells him
that he knows he's not human but he
isn't a shadow either he asks him why
he's protecting Jaime since he won't be
able to travel with her and the other
Shadows when the time comes but the man
just tells him that he must fulfill his
mother's wishes confused he asks why he
called Heine his mom and then he shows
him another picture of him from 40 years
ago he looks exactly the same age and is
holding heine's first son that she gave
birth to priest OG shadow guy then
reveals some nasty news he tells shinpei
that hiney has been giving birth to his
clone for the last 300 years he then
downloads his memory his Consciousness
his soul you will into the new baby each
time crushing its soul and then he lives
inside of that baby and that's the show
he's been living this whole time shocked
shinpei asks him the most important
question out of all of this did he do
the dirty with honey and he smiles
that's when Shadow usho begins to freak
out and tell shinpei to shoot OG Shadow
priest guy but he hesitates forcing
shout out Lucia to appear and she cuts
presky's head clean off seeing priest
guy dead they think they've just won the
war they call the rest of the squad
waiting outside and tell them that OG
Shadow has just died but out of nowhere
shadow ushio gets stabbed by OG's Shadow
from behind dying she kicks the bucket
just a shinpei loses his and starts
firing big fatties at OG Shadow's gray
matter but is too late in a millisecond
he slaps on the shadow armor and Spears
shinpei right through his guts sending
him out of the temple and impales him
right into this tree while everyone else
outside here's the gunshot and quickly
goes in to try and take out OG's Shadow
but that's when the time Loop sets and
everything slows down literally for
shimpei he reaches out towards OG's
Shadow desperately trying to do anything
he can to save his friends but he can't
and can only watch as OG's Shadow gloats
inside shinpei arrives at his new reset
point where he was just a few hours
earlier but this time Shadow ushio is
nowhere to be found he realizes that his
best friend has died for good and now
he'll have to take out the shadow Army
without her what do you guys think about
the video don't forget to like subscribe
leave a comment down below let us know
what you think about the video and also
don't forget to check out our how to be
playlist